they'll tell you that it's cool that
everyone's doing it that you can stop
anytime you want they'll say it makes
food taste more delicious that it makes
sex even sexier that it'll take the edge
off but here's what nobody will tell you
nobody is what nobody will tell you what
the hell are you doing here you're the
reason we're making this video oh really
well that's very flattering
uh-huh rated R
Oh
I love singing and dancing hi folks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
50 Cent's suck your dick
well it's a great price you almost makes
me wish I had a dick for you to suck
dick that is yes
you were the most decorated offices in
this department what do you see
robbery gone wrong to me this wasn't a
robbery this was a hit someone out there
is killing puppet Brian Connie I'm a
woman that's okay even got a good time
for you we're gonna catch the bastards
who did these murders because bodies are
gonna start piling up doing the best
damn cops I've ever seen I'll have your
badge for this I'm in the [ __ ] FBI oh
yeah [ __ ] big
[Music]
oh god are you alright diamond this pure
it I'm not doing this through it
[Music]
oh sorry about your dead human friend
Phillip is still in he's servicing a
client is that what I think it is
[Music]
[Music]
you